resident evil village isn't just your
run-of-the-mill horror game
it's a bit more involved there's hidden
treasure a merchant
hunting inventory management and
exploration
if you're new to the series or even
survival horror in general
then welcome these tips will help you
find your footing
rather than trembling around every
corner in fear in this video i'm going
to break it down into three
sections combat exploration and the duke
where i'll provide tips and tricks in
each category you can also
find stamps below combat tip one
go for the knees i know you're going to
want to be a hot shot with your head
shots but in resident evil
going for the dome isn't always the best
option the game's werewolf-like enemies
lichens are unruly fairly unpredictable
dudes that scour the village
they'll go from gaining real quick on
you to slowly stalking you as they get
closer and closer but don't be
fooled aim for the head and they'll duck
and juke out of the way leading to some
wasted rounds
it's annoying instead a few shots to the
knees will bring them down along for
opportune head shooting
the hitbox on their legs is also much
more forgiving making it easier to aim
down and fire without getting too
precise about it and all the same
principles apply to these
cave dwelling ghoulies sort of dudes
just keep in mind that there's a variety
of enemies in village
some of which are more spongy while
others wear armor so this tip
isn't universal however you'll be
fighting lycans and ghouls the most
so this strategy will be the most
exhausted in your encounters
tip 2 time your counters if you block an
attack
you have a small window of time to press
block again and trigger a counter
that will kick your enemy back which
also disarms them as well as having a
knockback on ones around you
in some cases when you're surrounded and
overwhelmed deliberately taking the hit
blocking it and countering it pays off
in disarming an enemy
and staggering others to go in for that
old tip number one and pop them in the
knees
tip three sometimes it's okay to run and
no
it does not mean you're a coward what's
wrong mcfly
chicken the ghoulie dudes in particular
are slow and don't prance around like
the lycans
so sometimes it's better to save your
resources and simply go around them to
get to where you're going
now in classic risk reward fashion
killing them
does reward you lay the in-game currency
so just consider
resources and environment before getting
into an altercation
and as a bonus tip it's still okay to
run but set a mind down while you're at
it
bullets and a knife aren't your only
answers to a fight in some scenarios you
will be surrounded on all sides
so turning and running is the only way
to make some distance between you
and the enemy and while you're at it set
a mine down if you have one handy then
scurry off screw it throw a bite bomb at
them too
[Applause]
on to exploration being thorough is the
name of the game here
as it's vital to finding many things
from supplies for crafting
treasure for selling and ammunition that
is pivotal
in your survival and with each area
being pretty dense and even maze-like at
times
it pays off to take your time to scour
high and low
so tip number one always check your map
before leaving a room
the game has a nifty feature that allows
you to indicate whether you've collected
everything in a room
when it's blue that indicates the room
is clear and you've collected everything
otherwise it'll appear red if you're
having trouble clearing a room make sure
to look up
the ceiling for anything that sparkles
if you see it shoot it
these are crystals that can be sold to
the duke the jolly old merchant guy
some rooms will require a lockpick to
complete finishing or a locked door but
thankfully your map marks them once you
find them so it's easy to go back and
clear them out
which is very very nice lastly keep in
mind that there are some
areas you won't be able to return to so
again
it pays to be thorough along your
journey opposed to your map filled with
uncleared rooms and it's awful
tip 2 backtrack it's worth it while a
few areas won't be available later the
actual village
is an area you'll be returning to many
many times
the village is a connecting hub between
each major area of the game
one way or another you'll be returning
there and each time you'll return with
something that can likely
unlock something else whether it's a
wheel for a well a lever four bridge
lock picks or you know keys so before
trudging into the next new area
make sure to take a moment and circle
back around with your newly found
items but like anything else relative to
resident evil
be wary of the risk reward as sometimes
being a thorough player will reward you
with a big old treasure
or a new special gun but it also likely
means you may have to deal with an
onslaught of baddies ready to drain you
of your resources
tip three go hunting it definitely
doesn't feel great killing pigs and
goats just minding their own business in
an already dreadful village infested
with werewolves running around
but as it turns out the true enemy is in
fact
actually ethan winters
killing animals and taking their parts
to the duke has some big
benefits like making meals that will
permanently increase health
block resistance etc also be on the
lookout of pictures of special
animals hidden around the village
hunting these things down
are needed for creating certain special
recipes and while you're on a killing
spree make sure to shoot the crows too
as they drop extra lay as well the last
section
the duke tip 1 check that treasure
before you
sell it selling treasure is an important
loop of the game
giving you a bump in the funds needed to
acquire valuable upgrades
ammunition and health resources if
you're a resident evil 4 veteran
this is a near copy and paste version of
how that one worked
but before you sell something make sure
it isn't combinable with another piece
of treasure
this is thankfully indicated in its
description listed next to its value
finding the piece of treasure it
combines with greatly increases its
value
so consider holding off until you find
its combinable part
tip number two sell your guns as the
game progresses you'll naturally find
better versions of your arsenal along
the way
while you may have grown a sentimental
attachment to your starting pistol and
have
upgraded it all the way it takes up
inventory space
and as the game goes on that space will
become more and more scarce
so just sell it and use that lay to
upgrade your new guard
and while you're at it just sell the
ammo for weapons you don't use as
often and use that money to replenish
the weapons you use a lot
keep in mind that the duke's inventory
is also limited
but it does replenish with every new
area
so here are the big takeaways go for the
knees be thorough
and crows carry plenty of pocket change
be sure to check out all of our other
resident evil coverage
including our review and a detailed
timeline on the entire franchise which
is
quite a wild watch so links in the
description below this was kurt
thanks for watching and happy surviving
you